音楽ハチマキしてるんだけどな黒チームかよ後ろさんのねこうなってるんで終わらね
清聴いただきました
はい一紗緒フィットチーネ組のイタリアピッチャーすとじゃがりこのたらこバター所
一緒に食べてみてください
すごいことになりますもしよろしかったら動画くれたりしてやってくださいやり
ましょう
ぜひやりましょう3つ選んで組の一人アンピッチャーズ遠ざかりこのたらこバターず俺
はねちょっとにもこれだけでこれを出せることにてな姉子なんかというのはまで聞いて
ないからわからないわけですこれ実に興味深いね一発いっ
グリーはまぁまぁ美味しいんですよこれおいしいんですけど外れまー失敗も即玉をず
れるでしょ
twitter できただけだねほんとに来
映画どんな子なのかというか僕も知らないしでみんな知らないでしょ
野党ございっ
こともないというかもしれませんそれを目で学んだけど俺初めてだからさせから下がっ
てやってみましょう
あのでちょっとね牛とネ実は耳脳から今日までもマミーがゆえに売ってるグループは
いつも将来のことを話し合ったわけですよ
こうやってなんかちゃんと協力してくれる家族がいるということはとてもありがたい
ことです
ありがとう
じゃあさっそくやっていきましょうはいこちらです土地に区民と
パラボターズこっちが許されたので2つであります
髪型が気になる
親猫の髪の毛でも治したという感じかな
それ食べますいただきます
me
んをっ
うんなにこれえっアクエリアス違う
なんだこれなんかアンクチーナ説明できないんですけどやっぱできるは口で説明できる
んですけど何かブツブツブツブツって感じでした
em
何なんだなんてスズメちょいと
なんかね味できないんだじゃないですよ味的にはすぎリンゴみたいなんですねリンゴ
みたいなしなります
不思議なのはなんか口の中でずっとなるんですよ
レバーと言っても俺のの味覚が合ってるかわかんないが直黒ピットちね組イタリアン
ピーチ
子バターん
待ってネット上がないじゃあにフィットチーネないなぁ
ないないぞ多分練ったり情報はないですこれ
大変な大飯店ではボケの見立てでは僕なんですけどこの2つを一緒に食べると運でもう
1枚はとも自分大減るん誰
ちな馬だ俺の味覚は皆さんご存知の通り信用できるものではないのでちょっとしたら
個人差があるかもしれませんねだって俺が入った g ギンギンになるか同作がわかん
ないけどねこんなビーフを受けてくれた方は何味って言おうとしたんだろうと良かっ
たらみなさんもやってみてください
俺はありますととも私が変なブツブツがこうあったんでちょっと見ても分かっておりの
スター信用できないから良かったらみな
他の意見もお聞かせいただけるとありがとーございますじゃあ
食べ物から数
ます
しています